according to my Twitter you all want to
see me talk about the new Batman vs
Superman trailer and also according to
my Twitter no one gives a [ __ ] about
Zoolander 2 which is why I love you so a
new trailer for Batman vs Superman has
come out it's the trailer I wanted to
see for Batman vs Superman this isn't a
trailer that shows you the entire plot
is just it shows you cool [ __ ] that you
wanted to see to get you jacked for the
movie that's trailers job so here we are
good trailer the trailer starts out
washing away any doubt anyone might have
had for the ben affleck batman batman
rex these dudes in the warehouse is a
pretty sweet action sequence the trailer
is worth watching just for that opening
scene then it shows bruce wayne
life-debt aliens a [ __ ] head he's a dick
there's one percent chance he's here to
hurt us we have to take it as an
absolute right Bruce Wayne loved the vim
and vigor a little harsh but I like
where your hearts at and it shows them
fighting it is just really cool to see
because this is what I've wanted to see
for years ever since I was a child and I
learned of the idea that Batman and
Superman fighting in a movie might be a
possibility one day down the road yeah I
wanted to see that this song they play
in this trailer though I was like is
this another trailer playing sabotage oh
no it's not sabotage it just sounds an
awful lot like sabotage I also love that
shot where Superman is just standing
there in the Batmobile comes around like
oh me too run you over the drain just
bounces right off of them although one
of two possibilities one Batman knew the
Superman's indestructible and wasn't
gonna hurt him but she would imagine but
then you think like why would he do that
if he knew it wouldn't hurt him or the
second possibility he actually intended
to run this dude over and kill him man
Batman is harsh in his old age I mean
there's a lot of fast imagery in this
trailer everything from romance that you
see and just blips Batman shooting
something a Superman Superman just like
catching it in midair gotta love that
kind of styling Supes although there was
one shot that is worth noting and that's
this one right here it's very quick it's
very brief but it's in here it's that
shot of what I can only assess is
Apocalypse which we saw apocalypse
creatures in the last trailer although
I'd forgot to talk about it also in a
blip in this trailer and then you see
that it's like Batman's clearly on
apocalypse he's also in that outfit that
we see him in the trailer where he's in
the sand so apparently the sand scenes
isn't the sand it's apocalypse that or
it's earth and Darkseid's turning earth
into the next apocalypse which does kind
of freak me out in the assessment that
maybe this movie is a bit too crowded
you have Batman vs Superman you have
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman versus
doomsday if Lex Luthor being a dick
making doomsday fight Batman Superman
and Wonder
now we have dark side possibly in the
mix so I feel like this movie is going
to be half and half I feel like the
first half of its going to be Batman vs
Superman the second half is going to be
dawn of Justice but all in all I really
like this trailer this was the trailer
for Batman vs Superman I wanted last
time a trailer came out and I loved that
final shot for Superman swings at Batman
Batman is like bam and Superman's like
like you just block me Batman's look has
a blue mine that just happened tensions
like a rubberband just snap so the
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice final
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more